Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. And when the king arrived and the commoners saw him, they all knelt down before him, saying, Welcome, our lord King Richard. We will have no other king but you. And what Tyler, their captain and leader, prayed on behalf of the commoners that the king would permit them to seize and deal with all the wretches who had betrayed both him and the law. The king gave them permission to seize all those who were traitors and could be proved as such by due process of law. And the commoners required that from that moment onwards no man should be a serf, nor give homage nor any type of service to a lord, but should give four pence as rent for every acre of land.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。当国王抵达，平民们见到他时，都跪在他面前说：“欢迎您，我们的理查德国王。除了您，我们不会有别的国王。”他们的队长和领袖泰勒代表平民恳求国王，允许他们抓捕并处置所有背叛了他和法律的恶棍。国王准许他们抓捕所有叛徒，并允许通过正当法律程序证明其罪行。平民们还要求，从那一刻起，任何人都不应再是农奴，不必向领主效忠或提供任何形式的劳役，而应为每英亩土地支付四便士的租金。
They demanded also that no one should be forced to serve a lord, but should only ever work as he wished, and by means of such agreements as were mutually agreed. So that was a chronically describing one of the most famous moments in all English history. A mile end outside London, the 14th of June, 1381. On the one hand, the boy king, Richard II, and on the other, the rebels led by Watt Tyler, the great protagonist of the so-called Peasants' Revolt. And Tom, last time you gave us an absolutely masterful, dare I say,
他们还要求，任何人都不应被迫为领主服务，而应只按自己的意愿工作，并以双方商定的协议为准。这就是一位编年史家对英国历史上最著名时刻之一的描述。1381年6月14日，伦敦郊外的迈尔恩德。一边是少年国王理查二世，另一边是所谓的“农民起义”的主角瓦特·泰勒领导的叛军。汤姆，上次你给我们做了一个绝对大师级的，我敢说，
You can if you like. magisterial account of the origins and character of this Peasants' Revolt, which wasn't really a Peasants' Revolt, as you explained. And we ended, I think you chose a very well-judged metaphor. You said that Richard and his ministers were staring down the barrel. I did. That was the one, wasn't it? There was a cliche fest, wasn't it? The last episode.
如果你愿意，你可以这么说。对这次农民起义的起源和性质进行了权威的叙述，正如你所解释的，这其实并不是一场农民起义。我们结束时，我想你用了一个非常恰当的比喻。你说理查和他的大臣们正处于枪口之下。没错，就是那个，不是吗？上一集简直是陈词滥调的集合，对吧？
It was a cliche fest. They were staring down the barrel because the rebels are outside London and the king is inside. Do you want to just remind people what their grievances were and their demands? Well, because it's an unprecedented situation. I mean, that passage, the reason why it's such an iconic moment, the idea of an anointed king going out and negotiating with someone who stands at the head of commoners, mere commoners, it's astounding. And then agreeing to those commoners' terms. But how do we get there? How do we get to the situation where Richard is willing to put himself absolutely in the line of danger to go out and do these negotiations? Because you might think,
确实是陈词滥调的集合。他们处于枪口之下，因为叛军在伦敦城外，而国王在城内。你想提醒大家他们的不满和要求是什么吗？嗯，因为这是一个前所未有的局面。我的意思是，那段文字之所以成为标志性时刻，是因为一位受膏的国王竟然走出去，与站在平民——仅仅是平民——之首的人进行谈判，这太令人震惊了。而且还同意了那些平民的条件。但我们是怎么走到这一步的呢？理查怎么会愿意让自己置身于绝对的危险之中，走出去进行这些谈判？因为你可能会想，
particularly if you are a peasant who is perhaps standing on Blackheath next to Tyler, gazing down the Thames towards London, you are staring at, by miles, the largest city in England. A very, very formidable and intimidating sight. Most of the rebels will not have seen London before, so the likelihood is that they will be very overawed by the spectacle. London has about 50,000 people at this time. I mean, so maybe three times as much as the next larger cities, York or Norwich or Bristol. It's pretty much recovered from the plague. The docks are crowded with ships. There are cranes everywhere. The streets are so crowded that people have begun basically building loft conversions.
特别是如果你是一个农民，也许正站在泰勒旁边的布莱克希斯，凝视着泰晤士河对岸的伦敦，你面对的是英国最大的城市，而且大得多。这是一个非常、非常令人生畏和威慑的景象。大多数叛军以前没见过伦敦，所以他们很可能会被这种场面所震慑。当时伦敦大约有五万人。我的意思是，这可能是下一个大城市约克、诺里奇或布里斯托尔的三倍。它基本上已经从瘟疫中恢复过来。码头上挤满了船只。到处都是起重机。街道拥挤不堪，人们基本上已经开始建造阁楼改造了。
So they're kind of building upwards. So the streets become kind of even more crowded. And I think that if you are a peasant gazing at this great city, you are noticing some very obvious structures that are going to alarm you. So you are most obviously going to notice the Tower of London, which is by far the most kind of forbidding fortress in the city. And this is where the leading officials of the royal government have taken refuge. So the king himself, his mother, the wife of the Black Prince, Sudbury, the Archbishop of Canterbury, Hales, the treasurer, John Legge, the upskirter. That's not an official title, I should emphasize. The upskirter persuadant. So that's where they are. And no one has ever captured the Tower of London. So it has a reputation for being impregnable. Beyond that, you have the great
所以他们是在向上扩建。街道变得更加拥挤。我想，如果你是一个凝视着这座伟大城市的农民，你会注意到一些非常明显的建筑，它们会让你感到不安。你最明显会注意到伦敦塔，它是城里最令人生畏的堡垒。皇家政府的主要官员都在这里避难。所以国王本人、他的母亲、黑太子的妻子、坎特伯雷大主教萨德伯里、财政大臣黑尔斯、约翰·莱格，那个“掀裙子的人”。我得强调，这不是一个正式头衔。掀裙子的追随者。所以他们就在那里。从来没有人攻克过伦敦塔。所以它以坚不可摧而闻名。除此之外，你还有伟大的
spire of St. Paul's and the Bishop of London, which previously had been Sudbury, who's now Archbishop of Canterbury. He exercises ecclesiastical jurisdiction over Essex. So St. Paul's is also an intimidating place. Beyond St. Paul's, you can just about probably make out the Twin Towers of Westminster Abbey, founded by Edward the Confessor, who is Richard II's particular patron. And Westminster, of course, is the great centre of royal power. And Westminster Hall still stands, part now of the Houses of Parliament. This is the great depository of records. So that's also very much on the target list of the assembled rebels. And of course, between Westminster and the City of London, on the Strand, this road which runs next to the Thames, hence its name, you have Savoy Palace, which is the great headquarters of John of Gaunt, the most powerful man in the kingdom, the uncle of the king, by miles the richest person in England, and an object of great hatred among many different strands of people. So he's very much disliked
圣保罗大教堂的尖顶，以及伦敦主教，他之前是萨德伯里，现在是坎特伯雷大主教。他对埃塞克斯行使教会管辖权。所以圣保罗大教堂也是一个令人畏惧的地方。在圣保罗大教堂之外，你大概能辨认出威斯敏斯特教堂的双塔，它由忏悔者爱德华建立，他是理查二世特别的守护神。当然，威斯敏斯特是王权的核心。威斯敏斯特大厅至今仍屹立不倒，现在是议会大厦的一部分。这是记录的伟大存放处。所以这也是聚集的叛军的目标清单上的重要目标。当然，在威斯敏斯特和伦敦城之间，在河岸街，这条紧邻泰晤士河的道路，因此得名，你有萨伏伊宫，这是约翰·冈特的总部，他是王国中最有权势的人，国王的叔叔，是英国最富有的人，也是许多不同阶层的人极度憎恨的对象。所以他非常不受
by the rebels outside London. But as we will find out, there are also people within London who have reason to dislike him. However, John of Gaunt is not in London at this time. He is away in the north, busy negotiating a truce with the Scots. However, his son, his only son, Henry of Derby, as he's called, Henry Bolingbroke, the 14-year-old cousin of Richard II, he is in London and has taken refuge with his cousin Richard in the Tower. Oh, the irony, Tom. The irony. Very nice. So these are ironies that we will tease out later in this series. So the rebels are gathered on Blackheath. They don't immediately advance. By now, it's the 12th of June. And the reason that
伦敦城外叛军的欢迎。但正如我们将要发现的那样，伦敦城内也有人有理由不喜欢他。然而，约翰·冈特此时不在伦敦。他在北方忙于与苏格兰人谈判停战。不过，他的儿子，唯一的儿子，被称为德比伯爵的亨利，即亨利·博林布鲁克，理查二世14岁的堂弟，他在伦敦，并与他的堂兄理查一起在塔中避难。哦，这讽刺，汤姆。这讽刺。非常好。所以这些是我们将在本系列后面梳理出来的讽刺。叛军聚集在布莱克希斯。他们没有立即前进。现在已经是6月12日了。而原因就是
they don't is that for them, there is only one crossing point into London, and that is London Bridge. There are no other bridges across the Thames. And London Bridge is held against them on the orders of the mayor, who is a man called William Walworth. Meanwhile, on the northern bank, the rebels from Essex and Suffolk have gathered on Mile End, which is described by a chronicler at the time as a fine open space situated in the middle of a pleasant meadow. Anyone who lives in Mile End now probably won't recognise that description. There's a kind of standoff, except that in the afternoon of the 12th, various bands of rebels from Blackheath start advancing along the South Bank of the Thames, because there are settlements that are along the Bank of the Thames. So the Southwark,
他们没有前进是因为对他们来说，进入伦敦只有一个过境点，那就是伦敦桥。泰晤士河上没有其他桥梁。而伦敦桥在市长威廉·沃尔沃斯的命令下被封锁，以抵御他们。与此同时，在北岸，来自埃塞克斯和萨福克的叛军聚集在迈尔恩德，当时的编年史家将其描述为“位于宜人草地中间的一片优美的开阔地”。现在住在迈尔恩德的人可能认不出这个描述了。这是一种僵局，只是在12日下午，来自布莱克希斯的各路叛军开始沿着泰晤士河南岸推进，因为泰晤士河沿岸有一些定居点。所以南华克，
which is on the South side of London Bridge, and you have some very famous prisons there. You have the Marshallsea, which lasts right the way up to the 19th century. Little Dorrit. Yeah. So Dickens' father ends up being in prison there. It's chiefly a place for debtors. And you have the Clink, which is such a famous prison that it's kind of become a name that serves for all prisons. And the rebels descend on them, open them up, release the prisoners. They also target local informers, which suggests that by this point, they are being joined by people who are from Southwark or perhaps from further afield. So in the histories of this period,
它位于伦敦桥南侧，那里有一些非常著名的监狱。你有马夏尔西监狱，一直持续到19世纪。《小杜丽》。是的。所以狄更斯的父亲最终被关在那里。它主要是债务人的地方。你还有克林克监狱，它非常出名，以至于它成了一个所有监狱的代名词。叛军冲向它们，打开大门，释放囚犯。他们还针对当地的告密者，这表明此时他们正与来自南华克或可能来自更远地方的人汇合。所以在这一时期的历史中，
you get rebels from notorious trouble spots such as Wandsworth, Tooting, Ballam, all these places that are now kind of, well, they're not hotbeds of rebellion, I think it would be fair to say. These were all villages at the time there, right? They're all little villages south of London. And there is one place, of course, that is a particular object of hatred for the rebels. And that is Lambeth Palace, which stands on the south side of the Thames and is the London home of the Archbishop of Canterbury, Sudbury, who the rebels from Kent particularly hate. And so they descend on it and there's a great orgy of sacking. Chancery rolls are burned, legal documents are pulled out and trashed. They find the wine cellar, they crack open the wine.
你会看到来自臭名昭著的麻烦地区的叛军，比如旺兹沃思、图廷、巴勒姆，所有这些现在……好吧，我想说它们不是叛乱的温床。这些当时都是村庄，对吧？它们都是伦敦南部的几个小村庄。当然，有一个地方是叛军特别憎恨的对象。那就是兰贝斯宫，它位于泰晤士河南岸，是坎特伯雷大主教萨德伯里的伦敦住所，肯特的叛军特别恨他。于是他们冲向那里，进行了一场大肆洗劫。大法官的卷宗被烧毁，法律文件被拖出来毁坏。他们找到了酒窖，撬开了酒。
And in Westminster Abbey, which sits on the other side of the Thames, they look over and a monk reports cries of, a revel, a revel, as they burn all the legal documents and imbibe the wine. So that's that thing that's always there in revolutions and rebellions, which people sometimes miss. Fun. It's fun. Yeah. It's a tremendous laugh when you're in the giddy height of it. Yes. Seized with the ecstasy of destruction.
在泰晤士河另一边的威斯敏斯特教堂，他们望过去，一位僧侣报告说听到了“狂欢，狂欢”的叫喊声，因为他们烧毁了所有的法律文件并畅饮葡萄酒。这就是革命和叛乱中总是存在的东西，人们有时会忽略它。乐趣。这很有趣。是的，当你处于那种眩晕的高潮时，这真是太搞笑了。是的。被破坏的狂喜所攫住。
And particularly if you've got the Archbishop of Canterbury's wine cellar at hand as well. I mean, that kind of fuels it. Absolutely. So meanwhile, the rebels have sent Sir John Newington, who people who heard the previous episode, he was the constable of Rochester Castle who'd been captured and is now being used as their emissary. And they have Sir John Newington's children as hostages, so he has no choice but to do what they say. He goes to the tower and he assures the king that he is in no danger. He says that the rebels hold and will hold you for their king. This is absolutely true. The rebels are very, very royalist. This is absolutely not the French Revolution. The reason that they admire and respect the king so much is that they see owing your lands to the king directly
特别是如果你手头还有坎特伯雷大主教的酒窖。我的意思是，这起到了推波助澜的作用。绝对是。所以与此同时，叛军派出了约翰·纽因顿爵士，听过上一集的人知道，他是罗切斯特城堡的警长，被俘虏后现在被用作他们的特使。他们扣押了约翰·纽因顿爵士的孩子作为人质，所以他别无选择，只能听命于他们。他前往塔楼，向国王保证他没有危险。他说叛军拥护并将继续拥护你为国王。这是绝对真实的。叛军是非常、非常保皇的。这绝对不是法国大革命。他们如此钦佩和尊重国王的原因是，他们认为直接向国王效忠
as being much better than owing it to various feudal intermediaries, so magnates or abbeys or whatever. There's a feeling that if you hold your lands directly from the king, then everything is good, that the king can be trusted. And Tom, there's a couple of things here. So people always sort of have this fantasy of the king as being good, and he's being betrayed by corrupt advisors. That's one thing. But is there also an element of them sentimentalizing and. And for Richard II, who's a 14-year-old boy who has not had control of the government at all, this is actually quite an intoxicating realization, I think. The sense that he has an authority and a charisma that no one else in his government has. And this, I think, will have quite enduring consequences for the rest of the reign. However, for now, he remains very much under the thumb of his advisors.
比向各种封建中间人，即权贵或修道院等效忠要好得多。有一种感觉，如果你直接从国王那里获得土地，那么一切都很好，国王是可以信任的。汤姆，这里有几件事。人们总是幻想国王是好的，是被腐败的顾问出卖了。这是一回事。但他们是否也有感伤的成分？对于14岁的理查二世来说，他根本没有控制政府，这实际上是一个相当令人陶醉的认识，我想。那种他拥有政府中其他人所没有的权威和魅力感。我认为，这对他的余生将产生相当持久的影响。然而，目前，他仍然完全处于顾问的控制之下。
And they say, okay, this is what we'll do. You get on a royal barge and tomorrow morning we will go down. You have a royal manor at Rotherhithe, which is between Blackheath and London Bridge. And you can sail down there and you can meet the leaders of the rebellion and negotiate with them. So this is what happens. 13th of June, Richard hears mass in the chapel of the tower, gets onto the barge. They head down towards Rotherhithe and they're appalled to discover that there aren't just a few rebels waiting for him, but the whole kind of mass. People say 200,000 men. Don't know if those figures are accurate, but a large, large quantity of people. Richard is perfectly happy to go and negotiate with them still. He's
他们说，好吧，我们就这么做。你坐上皇家驳船，明天早上我们下去。你在罗瑟希德有一个皇家庄园，它位于布莱克希斯和伦敦桥之间。你可以航行到那里，会见叛乱的领导人并与他们谈判。所以事情就是这样发生的。6月13日，理查在塔楼的礼拜堂听弥撒，登上驳船。他们向罗瑟希德方向驶去，却震惊地发现等待他的不仅仅是几个叛军，而是整整一大群人。人们说有20万人。不知道这些数字是否准确，但人数非常、非常多。理查仍然非常乐意去和他们谈判。他
personally very brave, but his advisors say, no, there's no way we're risking that. And so they steer the barge around and they go back to the tower. And this infuriates the rebels. And so they advance en masse to London Bridge. And despite the orders that the mayor, William Woolworth, has given, no attempt is made to hold it. And this is probably because London Bridge is key to the prosperity of London. So they just don't want to risk it being destroyed. Right.
个人非常勇敢，但他的顾问们说，不，我们绝不能冒这个险。于是他们调转驳船，回到了塔楼。这激怒了叛军。于是他们集体向伦敦桥推进。尽管市长威廉·沃尔沃斯下达了命令，但并没有试图守住它。这可能是因为伦敦桥对伦敦的繁荣至关重要。所以他们只是不想冒被摧毁的风险。对。
Yeah. The city fathers. Because as you said, it's the only bridge across the Thames. Yeah. That surprised me. I didn't realise that. It's the great pivot for the whole kingdom, really. And if that goes, then that's terribly bad for the financial prospects of all the merchants in the city who are basically running it. But I think also it suggests that, well, we know from what subsequently happens,
是的。城市元老们。因为正如你所说，它是泰晤士河上唯一的桥梁。是的。这让我很惊讶。我没意识到这一点。它确实是整个王国的伟大枢纽。如果它没了，那对城里基本上在经营它的所有商人的财务前景来说都是极其糟糕的。但我认为这也表明，好吧，我们从随后发生的事情中知道，
that the rebels have a lot of sympathisers in London. It may be that the gatekeepers themselves are sympathisers. We know that the keeper of one of the gates, Cripplegate, is subsequently arraigned for having opened them. It just suggests that there was no real prospect of holding London, that the bushfires of rebellion, Dominic, are waiting to flare into life within the city as well as without. Right. Okay. So the rebels from Kent cross London Bridge. Meanwhile, the rebels from Mile End have forced their way in through Aldgate, which is the gate in the east, and they very rapidly take control of London. And as had been the case in Kent and Essex. So now in London, the destruction is very, very targeted.
叛军在伦敦有很多同情者。可能守门人本身就是同情者。我们知道其中一个城门——克里普尔门的守门人后来因打开城门而被传讯。这只是表明，守住伦敦根本没有希望，叛乱的野火，多米尼克，正在城内和城外等待着爆发。对。好吧。所以来自肯特的叛军穿过了伦敦桥。与此同时，来自迈尔恩德的叛军强行通过了东部的奥尔德门，他们非常迅速地控制了伦敦。正如在肯特和埃塞克斯的情况一样。所以现在在伦敦，破坏是非常、非常有针对性的。
So there are some very predictable objects of the looting and vandalism that now ensues. So listeners from the previous episode, we mentioned Sir John Hales, who is the Lord Treasurer and therefore very hated as the guy who is held responsible for the poll tax. But he's also the prior of the Knights Hospitallers. And the Knights Hospitallers have their headquarters in Clerkenwell at the Priory of St. John of Jerusalem. And this is systematically disassembled. All the charters, all the court rolls, all the writings and everything taken out and
所以随之而来的抢劫和破坏有一些非常可预测的目标。所以上一集的听众，我们提到了约翰·黑尔斯爵士，他是财政大臣，因此作为被认为对人头税负责的人而非常招人恨。但他也是医院骑士团的院长。医院骑士团在克勒肯维尔的耶路撒冷圣约翰修道院设有总部。这被系统地拆解了。所有的宪章、所有的法庭卷宗、所有的文书和一切都被拿走并
burnt, as happens again and again throughout this rebellion. And then the whole of the priory is torched and it is said that the fires burn for seven days. But of course, Dominic, the obvious, the prime target for the rebels is Savoy Palace. John of Gaunt's palace. John of Gaunt's great headquarters. This is raised so thoroughly to the ground that basically not a brick is left standing and there's no prospect of John of Gaunt putting it back together again.
烧毁，正如在这场叛乱中一次又一次发生的那样。然后整个修道院被付之一炬，据说大火烧了七天。但当然，多米尼克，叛军的首要目标是萨伏伊宫。约翰·冈特的宫殿。约翰·冈特的伟大总部。这被彻底夷为平地，基本上连一块砖都没剩下，约翰·冈特也没有重建它的希望了。
Again, all the records are destroyed, but so too are Gaunt's possessions. And what's fascinating is that the rebels make a point not of taking them away, of stealing these property, but of destroying them. So, you know, furs and tapestries and so on are burnt. Anything that they can't burn, so gold and silver plate or jewels or whatever, they just go and dump in the Thames. And they make a real point of this to the extent that anyone who is found looting is killed. So for instance, someone steals a silver plate and is thrown into the flames. And there's a very salutary tale that is much repeated that 30 of the rebels had broken into John of Gaunt's wine cellar and had got riotously drunk on it. The
同样，所有的记录都被销毁了，冈特的财产也是如此。令人着迷的是，叛军的重点不是拿走它们，不是偷窃这些财产，而是销毁它们。所以，你知道，皮草和挂毯等等都被烧了。任何他们烧不掉的东西，比如金银餐具或珠宝什么的，他们就直接扔进泰晤士河。他们确实对此非常坚持，以至于任何被发现抢劫的人都会被杀。例如，有人偷了一个银盘子，就被扔进了火里。有一个非常警示的故事被反复提及，30名叛军闯入了约翰·冈特的酒窖，并在里面喝得酩酊大醉。
palace then collapsed on top of them and they were trapped underneath. They were stuck there for seven days until they all died of starvation. All that suggests to me that the spirit that is moving them and doing all this is probably quite religious because of course at the time there would be no sense of or very little sense of political commitment that wasn't religious, that wasn't seen in Christian terms. So am I right in thinking what we talked about last time, the proto-Protestant element is probably quite strong there when they're sacking John O'Gorn's palace. Puritanical. I think to a degree.
宫殿随后倒塌在他们身上，他们被困在下面。他们被困在那里七天，直到全部饿死。所有这些向我表明，推动他们并做这一切的精神可能相当具有宗教色彩，因为当然在当时，如果没有宗教色彩，没有从基督教角度来看待的政治承诺，那是不可能的。所以我认为我们上次谈到的原始新教元素在他们洗劫约翰·冈特宫殿时可能相当强烈，这种想法对吗？清教徒式的。我认为在某种程度上是这样。
So they cast themselves as lovers of truth and justice, not robbers and thieves. They feel that they are summoning England to a better future. Right. And therefore they want to present themselves as very much as agents of light. But it is also clear that there are elements within London who sees this as an opportunity to get their own back on their enemies. So many of these are highly wealthy, in fact, some of the wealthiest people in the kingdom. So these are London merchants who like to exercise monopolies over various aspects of trade, but which John of Gaunt,
所以他们把自己塑造成真理和正义的追求者，而不是强盗和窃贼。他们觉得他们正在召唤英国走向一个更美好的未来。对。因此，他们想把自己表现为光明的使者。但同样清楚的是，伦敦内部有一些人认为这是一个向敌人报复的机会。所以这些人中许多是非常富有的人，事实上，是王国中最富有的人。这些是伦敦商人，他们喜欢对贸易的各个方面行使垄断权，但约翰·冈特，
in his role as the leading figure in the royal government, has been selling to foreign merchants. This has generated enormous resentment among the leading figures in the city. It's generated immense hatred for the foreigners among them, the Italians and the Fleming merchants, but it also means that John of Gaunt himself is particularly hated. And although lots of the places in London that are targeted are kind of obvious, their prisons again, their kind of record offices, you do also get the deliberate targeting of people who wouldn't be known to rebels from Essex or Kent. And the key figure is a guy called Sir Richard Lyons, who is the son of
作为皇家政府的领军人物，一直在把这些卖给外国商人。这在城里的领军人物中引起了巨大的不满。这在他们中间引起了对外国人——意大利人和弗拉芒商人——的极大仇恨，但也意味着约翰·冈特本人特别招人恨。虽然伦敦许多被针对的地方是显而易见的，比如监狱、记录办公室，但你也会看到针对那些埃塞克斯或肯特的叛军所不认识的人的蓄意攻击。关键人物是一个叫理查德·莱昂斯爵士的人，他是
a Norfolk landowner and a Flemish mother. He is always referred to as a Fleming, even though he's half English. He is a financier, a monopolist. He had the monopoly on the sale of sweet wine. He is repeatedly accused of fraud against the Exchequer. He is hated by his fellow monopolists in London as an ally of John of Gaunt. In fact, his effigy in the church of St. Martin Vintry, which is one of the wards in the city of London, gets destroyed in the Great Fire. But we know from an Elizabethan account of London that he was portrayed holding an enormous wallet, which basically sums him up. He is targeted, he's dragged out from his house, and he is beheaded publicly on cheap side. So you get the sense that leading figures in the city who, under normal circumstances,
一个诺福克地主和一个弗拉芒母亲的儿子。他总是被称为弗拉芒人，尽管他有一半英国血统。他是一个金融家、垄断者。他拥有甜酒销售的垄断权。他一再被指控欺诈国库。他被伦敦的同行垄断者视为约翰·冈特的盟友而受到憎恨。事实上，他在圣马丁温特里教堂（伦敦城的一个区）的雕像在伦敦大火中被毁。但我们从伊丽莎白时代关于伦敦的记载中知道，他被描绘成拿着一个巨大的钱包，这基本上概括了他。他被盯上了，被从家里拖出来，在奇普赛德被公开斩首。所以你会感觉到城里的领军人物，在正常情况下，
would in no way identify with the aims of rebels, of peasants. They see the chaos as an opportunity to get their own back on financial rivals. Right, because the people who are striking at Lyons, let's say, I mean, the people in Essex and Kent couldn't give a damn about it. They don't even know who he is, presumably. Well, Lyons is so notorious that he does have a bad reputation in Essex and Kent because he owns properties out there. But I think that they wouldn't know where his house was in London. The people who are staging this kind of judicial murder are clearly operating with the say-so of his commercial rivals within the city. So it's all chaos. And meanwhile, poor old Rich II is on the White Tower gazing out across London.
绝不会认同农民叛军的目标。他们把混乱视为向金融竞争对手报复的机会。对，因为那些打击莱昂斯的人，我是说，埃塞克斯和肯特的人根本不在乎。他们大概连他是谁都不知道。嗯，莱昂斯太臭名昭著了，他在埃塞克斯和肯特确实名声不好，因为他在那里有房产。但我认为他们不知道他在伦敦的房子在哪里。那些策划这种司法谋杀的人显然是在城内他的商业竞争对手的授意下行动的。所以一切都是混乱的。与此同时，可怜的理查二世在白塔上凝视着伦敦。
And he's basically thinking. Oh, no. Oh, God. And just for a second, Tom, I know we've got to go to a break. But Richard II, just in a couple of sentences, give us some sense of his personality. I mean, he's only 14 years old, but he's a very bright boy. He has an elevated sense of himself, doesn't he? Very elevated, yeah.
他基本上在想。哦，不。哦，天哪。汤姆，就一秒钟，我知道我们得去休息一下。但理查二世，就用几句话，让我们了解一下他的个性。我的意思是，他才14岁，但他是一个非常聪明的男孩。他有一种崇高的自我意识，不是吗？非常崇高，是的。
Do we know much about his character at this point? We know that he is very conscious of his dignity as king. We know that he is very smart and we know that he is very brave, but we also know that he is untested, that he is only 14. And the question of how much agency he has in what follows is contested because we just don't know. However, I suspect that he probably has more agency than he would have done in a situation where the royal government is still cohering. Because it becomes clear that day that London gets taken by the rebels that actually Richard's advisors have no idea really what to do. So they try and get the rebels to disperse by offering a general pardon. And this doesn't work because the rebels
我们现在对他的人格了解多吗？我们知道他非常清楚自己作为国王的尊严。我们知道他非常聪明，我们也知道他非常勇敢，但我们也知道他未经考验，他才14岁。关于他在随后的事情中有多少能动性是有争议的，因为我们只是不知道。然而，我怀疑他可能比在皇家政府仍然团结一致的情况下拥有更多的能动性。因为那天伦敦被叛军占领时，很明显理查的顾问们真的不知道该怎么办。所以他们试图通过提供大赦来让叛军散去。但这没用，因为叛军
say they won't until serfdom has been abolished, until the traitors in the tower have been handed over. And since the traitors in the tower have been handed over. And since the traitors in the tower are basically the royal government, they're stuck. They're not quite sure what to do. And so they stand there and they watch as the fires spread and more and more of their manners and their properties are destroyed. And so as dust starts to fall, the mayor, William Woolworth, who is very punchy, he suggests that they should get, you know, all the troops they can and sally out from the tower.
说除非农奴制被废除，除非塔里的叛徒被交出来，否则他们不会散去。既然塔里的叛徒基本上就是皇家政府，他们就陷入了困境。他们不太确定该怎么办。所以他们站在那里，看着大火蔓延，他们越来越多的庄园和财产被摧毁。所以当尘埃开始落下时，市长威廉·沃尔沃斯，他非常有冲劲，他建议他们应该召集他们能召集的所有军队，从塔里冲出去。
He says that, you know, these people aren't soldiers, we can destroy them. But there are very proficient military figures in the tower with Richard, of whom the most experienced soldier is the Earl of Salisbury, a veteran of the Hundred Years' War. And he says, no, don't do it. We haven't got enough men. And we risk two things. We risk an absolute bloodbath and we risk the possibility that we won't be able to prevail. And so by the next morning, Richard's counsellors have decided that they have no choice but to allow the king to go out and negotiate. The one thing they didn't previously want to do, right?
他说，你知道，这些人不是士兵，我们可以消灭他们。但理查的塔里有一些非常精通军事的人物，其中最有经验的士兵是索尔兹伯里伯爵，他是百年战争的老兵。他说，不，别这么做。我们没有足够的人手。我们冒着两个风险。我们冒着绝对血流成河的风险，我们还冒着我们可能无法获胜的风险。所以到第二天早上，理查的顾问们决定他们别无选择，只能允许国王出去谈判。他们之前唯一不想做的事情，对吧？
The one thing they didn't previously want to do. And the question is, are they sending Richard out to negotiate in good faith or not? I think the counsellors almost certainly are not. I mean, of course they're not because they face probably being lynched if the rebels have their way. But I think maybe for Richard, it's different because he is by now very aware that the rebels have a strong personal devotion to him. And if you're a king and you're 14 years old, I mean, this is quite invigorating. So anyway, so he gets on his horse and he rides out with his trusted advisors, people who will not serve as red rags to the bull Dominic, that is the mass of peasants, the mass of rebels. He's staring down the barrel again, isn't he?
他们之前唯一不想做的事情。问题是，他们派理查出去谈判是出于诚意吗？我认为顾问们几乎肯定不是。我的意思是，当然不是，因为如果叛军得逞，他们很可能面临被私刑处死的危险。但我认为也许对理查来说，情况不同，因为他现在非常清楚叛军对他有强烈的个人忠诚。如果你是一个国王，你才14岁，我的意思是，这相当令人振奋。所以无论如何，他骑上马，带着他信任的顾问们出发了，这些人不会像红布对公牛一样激怒多米尼克，也就是那群农民，那群叛军。他又处于枪口之下了，不是吗？
Yeah. So Richard rides out to Mile End, and there he meets with what Tyler and several hundred other of the rebels gathered around him. And the rebels complained to the king of their intolerable servitude, the phrases, and the heavy oppressions. And Richard hears them, and he says he understands their unhappiness, and he agrees to startling terms, which if they had been upheld, would have radically, radically altered the social fabric of England. So he agrees that, yes, serfdom shall be abolished, which is clearly a very radically egalitarian move. But at the same time, he also agrees to a kind of bonfire of the regulations, Dominic.
是的。所以理查骑马前往迈尔恩德，在那里他会见了瓦特·泰勒和聚集在他周围的几百名其他叛军。叛军向国王抱怨他们无法忍受的奴役，这是原话，以及沉重的压迫。理查听了他们的话，说他理解他们的不幸，并同意了惊人的条款，如果这些条款得到维持，将从根本上改变英国的社会结构。所以他同意，是的，农奴制将被废除，这显然是一个非常激进的平等主义举措。但与此同时，他也同意了一场法规的“大篝火”，多米尼克。
Nice. You know, supply-side reforms. The Daily Telegraph would love it. So all the kind of the monopolies, the tolls, the trading privileges that the various merchants in various towns, including London, the abbeys, the monasteries have habitually exercised, it's agreed that all these will be destroyed, that from this point on, commoners will have the right to trade as and where they please. It's a very, very radical free market maneuver. So it's simultaneously egalitarian and very free
不错。你知道，供给侧改革。《每日电讯报》会喜欢的。所以所有那些垄断、通行费、各种城镇（包括伦敦）、修道院、寺院习惯行使的贸易特权，都同意将全部废除，从这一点开始，平民将有权在他们喜欢的地点和时间进行贸易。这是一个非常、非常激进的自由市场策略。所以这些谈判同时是平等主义的和非常自由市场的。
market, these negotiations. What Richard doesn't agree to, as far as we can tell, despite the chronicle that you read saying that he does, is that the traitors, in inverted commas, should be handed over. But I think it's equally clear that in the eyes of the rebels who've been negotiating with him, this is essentially what Richard has agreed to. And so after the meeting, Richard doesn't go back to the tower. We're not quite sure where he goes, but he definitely doesn't go back to the tower. But the great mass of rebels who had been with him, they all head off towards the tower and they get in. And they get in because there's no defences, because Richard has withdrawn the defences conceivably? Well, we don't know how they get in.
理查没有同意的，据我们所知，尽管你读到的编年史说他同意了，是那些“叛徒”（加引号）应该被交出来。但我认为同样清楚的是，在与他谈判的叛军眼中，这基本上就是理查已经同意的事情。所以会议结束后，理查没有回到塔楼。我们不太确定他去了哪里，但他绝对没有回到塔楼。但一直和他在一起的那一大群叛军，他们都向塔楼走去，并进去了。他们进去了，因为没有防御，因为理查撤走了防御，可以想象吗？嗯，我们不知道他们是怎么进去的。
It's very strange because it's impregnable. There's no way that they would have been able to force it. So I think the likelihood is, and it's a reflection of the fact that this isn't really, again, a peasant's revolt. You know, there are people at the head of the rebels, probably in London, I mean, probably very, very eminent, distinguished figures who smooth talk their way in.
这很奇怪，因为它坚不可摧。他们不可能强行攻入。所以我认为可能性是，这反映了一个事实，即这再次不是真正的农民起义。你知道，叛军的首领中，可能在伦敦，我的意思是，可能是一些非常、非常杰出、显赫的人物，他们用甜言蜜语混了进去。
You know, they're talking to the guards. They say, we've come from the king. He says, you've got to let us in. smooth talk their way in. They're talking to the guards. They say, we've come from the king. He says, you've got to let us in. And so they break in. And again, the violence is very targeted. So in fact, only five people are executed. Simon Sudbury, the Archbishop of Canterbury, you'd expect him. It takes eight blows of the axe to chop off his head. Robert Hales, the treasurer. Yeah. John Legge, the upskirter persuadant. Right. He goes. Yeah. A lawyer from Stepney. Right.
你知道，他们和守卫交谈。他们说，我们是国王派来的。他说，你必须让我们进去。用甜言蜜语混了进去。他们和守卫交谈。他们说，我们是国王派来的。他说，你必须让我们进去。于是他们闯了进去。同样，暴力是非常有针对性的。所以事实上，只有五个人被处决。坎特伯雷大主教西蒙·萨德伯里，你会预料到他。砍下他的头用了八斧。财政大臣罗伯特·黑尔斯。是的。约翰·莱格，那个“掀裙子的追随者”。对。他去了。是的。一个来自斯特普尼的律师。对。
Who has clearly been targeted by some other, probably lawyer from Stepney. He's clearly been fingered. Right. Some vendetta, some local vendetta. And then the son of John of Gaunt, Henry, who people remember, we said he was in the tower. He manages to get away. A rebel from Rochester is supposed to have bundled him out, which is very sensible because in due course, the rebel is able to use this as a justification for why he shouldn't be put to death. But instead, the rebels, they vent their hatred for John of Gaunt on his physician, whom they find there.
他显然被其他人盯上了，可能是来自斯特普尼的律师。他显然被指认了。对。某种仇杀，某种当地的仇杀。然后是约翰·冈特的儿子亨利，人们记得，我们说过他在塔里。他设法逃脱了。一个来自罗切斯特的叛军据说是把他送了出去，这非常明智，因为在适当的时候，这个叛军能够以此作为他为什么不应该被处死的辩护。但相反，叛军把他们对约翰·冈特的仇恨发泄在他的医生身上，他们在那里找到了他。
That's harsh, isn't it? The guy's just doing his job. Yeah. Hippocratic oath, Tom. Yeah. Well, you'd say so. So anyway, so this is the state of play midway through this turbulent day on which the King of England has had negotiations with rebel leaders from Essex and from Kent.
这很残酷，不是吗？那家伙只是在做他的工作。是的。希波克拉底誓言，汤姆。是的。嗯，你会这么说。所以无论如何，这就是在这个动荡的一天中途的局势，英国国王与来自埃塞克斯和肯特的叛军领袖进行了谈判。
And the question now is, will it work? Will the rebels disperse? What's going to happen? And just as we go into the break, Tom, well, apart from the fact that this revolution, had it happened, would have completely reshaped English society, that thing about Henry Bolingbroke being bundled out by the bloke from Rochester, that is a momentous moment in English history, isn't it? It is. If he had been captured and executed, the fate of Richard and executed the fate of richard the second the fate of the plantagenet dynasty the whole course of english history might well have been very different and on that cliffhanger what a moment so we will be back after the break
现在的问题是，这会奏效吗？叛军会散去吗？会发生什么？就在我们进入休息时间之前，汤姆，除了这场革命如果发生将彻底重塑英国社会之外，关于亨利·博林布鲁克被那个罗切斯特人送出去的那件事，那是英国历史上一个重大的时刻，不是吗？确实是。如果他被俘虏并处决，理查二世的命运，金雀花王朝的命运，整个英国历史的进程可能都会大不相同。就在那个悬念上，多么重要的时刻。所以我们休息后会回来，
and we will find out are the peasant revolutionaries they're neither peasants nor revolutionaries, but that's neither here nor there. But are they going to succeed or will the wheel of fortune turn against them, Tom? Come back after the break and find out. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
我们会发现，那些农民革命者——他们既不是农民也不是革命者，但这无关紧要——他们会成功吗？还是命运之轮会转而反对他们，汤姆？休息后回来揭晓。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余味》。这是您每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest is History. The wheel of fortune is turning. And Tom, we ended last time with the rebels having got the concessions they wanted from Richard II, the most astounding concessions in English history. Yeah, incredible concessions. That would completely change the shape of England's social and economic order.
请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余味》。命运之轮正在转动。汤姆，我们上次结束时，叛军已经从理查二世那里得到了他们想要的让步，这是英国历史上最令人震惊的让步。是的，令人难以置信的让步。这将彻底改变英国社会和经济秩序的格局。
Yeah. The abolition of serfdom and so on, the egalitarianism of this new world that they're dreaming of. And they have stormed into the tower. They've executed five people, the Archbishop of Canterbury with eight blows of the axe, John de Gaunt's doctor, very harshly in my view, a man from Stepney because other people in Stepney don't like him. Now, what happens next? Right. Well, this is the key question. And all Richard's negotiations have been predicated on
是的。废除农奴制等等，他们梦想的这个新世界的平等主义。他们已经冲进了塔楼。他们处决了五个人，坎特伯雷大主教用了八斧，约翰·冈特的医生，在我看来非常残酷，一个来自斯特普尼的人，因为斯特普尼的其他不喜欢他的人。现在，接下来会发生什么？好吧，这是关键问题。理查所有的谈判都是基于
the fact that it will lead the rebels to disperse. And lots of them do. Lots of them do start heading back to Cairnt or to Essex or to Suffolk, but not all of them. And this is a real problem because it means that Richard still hasn't got London back under control. Emphasizing this is the fact that the severed heads of Sudbury, the Archbishop of Canterbury, and Hales, the treasurer, are being paraded through the streets on spikes. Then they are set up on London Bridge in the place where rebels' heads are always put. What this suggests is that the rebels themselves are now
一个事实，即这将导致叛军散去。他们中的许多人确实散去了。他们中的许多人开始返回肯特、埃塞克斯或萨福克，但并非全部。这是一个真正的问题，因为这意味着理查仍然没有让伦敦恢复控制。强调这一点的是，萨德伯里（坎特伯雷大主教）和黑尔斯（财政大臣）被砍下的头颅正被插在长矛上在街上游行。然后它们被放在伦敦桥上，放在叛军头颅总是被放置的地方。这表明叛军本身现在
kind of arrogating the powers of the state. This is all very, very unsettling. What's even more unsettling, particularly if you're a foreign merchant, is that roaming bands of mobs are hunting you down. Over 150 foreign merchants are killed. As we said in the first half, they are particularly associated with John of Gaunt. But in this period, an English mob never really needs an excuse to be xenophobic. And there are 35 Flemings who have taken sanctuary in a church, most notoriously, and they are dragged out and beheaded. And chroniclers write about how the streets are filled with piles of corpses. And so it's pretty obvious by the end of the day that Richard is going to have to go and meet the rebels again. To call them off, basically.
正在僭取国家权力。这一切都非常、非常令人不安。更令人不安的是，特别是如果你是一个外国商人，成群结队的暴徒正在追捕你。超过150名外国商人被杀。正如我们在上半部分所说，他们特别与约翰·冈特有关。但在这一时期，英国暴徒从来不需要借口来排外。有35名弗拉芒人在一座教堂里寻求庇护，最著名的是，他们被拖出来斩首。编年史家写道，街道上堆满了尸体。所以到一天结束时，很明显理查将不得不再次去会见叛军。基本上是为了叫停他们。
To see what he can do, to see if there's something that can be done to just… Calm them down. Yeah, to calm them down, to kind of pacify the whole situation. So the afternoon of the 15th of June, he goes to Westminster Abbey and he prays at the shrine of Edward the Confessor, who is his particular patron. And he then rides out to another open space, this time on the west side of the city of London, a place called Smithfield. Smithfield is where the Priory and the Hospital of St. Bartholomew stands. And this is one of the absolute key moments. So Richard goes there with Sir William Woolworth, who is the mayor of London. Who's a hard man, you said.
看看他能做什么，看看是否有什么办法可以……让他们冷静下来。是的，让他们冷静下来，平息整个局势。所以6月15日下午，他前往威斯敏斯特教堂，在忏悔者爱德华（他的特别守护神）的神龛前祈祷。然后他骑马前往另一个开阔地，这次是在伦敦城西侧，一个叫史密斯菲尔德的地方。史密斯菲尔德是圣巴塞洛缪修道院和医院所在地。这是绝对关键的时刻之一。所以理查和伦敦市长威廉·沃尔沃斯爵士一起去了那里。他是个硬汉，你说过。
Very robust in his disinclination to listen to rebels. Right. And also a very, very celebrated veteran of the Hundred Years' War, a man called Sir Robert Knowles. And they go to Smithfield and there is Wat Tyler and all the rebels. And Wat Tyler has the hapless Sir John Newington with him, the constable of Rochester Cathedral, who's been the emissary. And Sir John Newington escorts Wat Tyler over to the king. And Richard demands to know from Tyler, why haven't you gone? I've given you these concessions. What's up? And Wat Tyler says, well, we want more. We want all the poaching laws abolished
在不听叛军意见方面非常强硬。对。而且也是一位非常、非常著名的百年战争老兵，一个叫罗伯特·诺尔斯爵士的人。他们去了史密斯菲尔德，瓦特·泰勒和所有的叛军都在那里。瓦特·泰勒带着倒霉的约翰·纽因顿爵士，他是罗切斯特大教堂的警长，一直担任特使。约翰·纽因顿爵士护送瓦特·泰勒来到国王面前。理查要求泰勒解释，为什么你们还没走？我已经给了你们这些让步。怎么回事？瓦特·泰勒说，嗯，我们要更多。我们要废除所有的偷猎法。
so that we can go and shoot deer whenever we want. We're fed up with the right of manorial courts, the feudal lords having the right to try us in their courts. We want them abolished as well. And most startling of all, and this is where this idea of kind of proto-Protestantism, I think, really seems evident. Tyler demands that the entire hierarchy of the church be swept away and that there be only one person left in charge of the church. That the clergy should lose all their property, that it should be divided up among their parishioners, and that religious communities should only have enough to live on. They shouldn't own anything more than that. And I think it's hard not to see the influence of John Ball there on those demands. So Tom, just on that, is this what Tyler now sort of rummaging around to try and find excuses for the fact that there's been this violence, this orgy of xenophobic violence?
这样我们就可以随时去猎鹿了。我们受够了庄园法庭的权利，受够了封建领主有权在他们的法庭上审判我们。我们也希望废除这些。最令人震惊的是——我认为这正是某种原始新教思想显而易见的地方——泰勒要求彻底扫除整个教会等级制度，教会只由一个人负责。神职人员应该失去所有财产，这些财产应该分给他们的教区居民，宗教团体应该只保留维持生活所需的物资。他们不应该拥有超过这些的东西。我认为很难不从中看到约翰·鲍尔对这些要求的影响。那么汤姆，就这一点而言，泰勒现在是否在东拉西扯，试图为这场暴力事件，这场排外暴力的狂欢寻找借口？
In other words, he's now falling back on, you know, let's think of something else to say, partly because he thinks, well, we can't really go home because if we go home, they'll probably renege on all their promises and we won't get the order we want. No, but I think because Richard has given his word on oath and a king's word on oath is something that I think the rebels would all trust. And so I think that actually it's probably the opposite. The rebels think Richard is their friend, that he can be trusted, and that if he's given them as much as he already has done, well, why not ask for more? I suspect is what is going on there. But this thing about the abolition of much of the church hierarchy, that would be very shocking to
换句话说，他现在退而求其次，你知道，想点别的说法，部分原因是他认为，好吧，我们真的不能回家，因为如果我们回家，他们可能会违背所有的承诺，我们就得不到我们想要的秩序。不，但我认为是因为理查德已经宣誓，而国王的誓言是叛军都会信任的东西。所以我认为事实可能恰恰相反。叛军认为理查德是他们的朋友，他是可以信任的，如果他已经给了他们这么多，那么，为什么不要求更多呢？我怀疑这就是当时的情况。但是关于废除大部分教会等级制度的事情，这对很多人来说会非常令人震惊，不是吗？
a lot of people, wouldn't it? Perhaps more shocking than the economic reforms, than the abolition of serfdom or something. Because they have been brought up to believe in the church. There must have been a lot of people who had joined this revolt who would not have gone along with that. Well, but equally, and this is part of the swirl of political loyalties in this period, it's so confusing. There are elements of this program, of the disestablishment of the church, if you want to put it like that, that derive from the teachings of John Wycliffe, who was a very significant, radical Christian teacher at Oxford, who is a very significant, radical Christian teacher at Oxford, who has been particularly patronized by John of Gaunt.
也许比经济改革、比废除农奴制之类的东西更令人震惊。因为他们从小就被教导要信仰教会。一定有很多加入这场起义的人并不赞同这一点。嗯，但同样地，这也是这一时期政治忠诚漩涡的一部分，太令人困惑了。这个纲领中有些要素，如果你愿意这样说的话，关于教会的非国教化，源于牛津大学一位非常重要、激进的基督教教师约翰·威克里夫的教义，他特别受到冈特的约翰的赞助。
So weirdly, there's a kind of a coincidence of aims with John Ball, this kind of vagabond preacher who has been inspiring the rebels out in the counties, and John Wycliffe, this brilliant academic who is sponsored by John of Gaunt. And so we just don't know what the cross-currents are there. So Richard agrees to all these terms again, but I suspect that by now, he has no intention of upholding those. So we don't know precisely the terms in which he agrees it because what happens almost immediately after he agrees to these terms is that there's a fracas and the events are so confused that the precise outline of action is uncertain. But essentially what seems to have happened is that what Tyler is thirsty, it's hot. He asks for a jug of water and then he downs that and then he
所以奇怪的是，约翰·鲍尔——这个在各郡激励叛军的流浪传教士——和约翰·威克里夫——这个由冈特的约翰资助的杰出学者——的目标竟然有一种巧合。所以我们只是不知道其中的暗流是什么。理查德再次同意了所有这些条款，但我怀疑到目前为止，他根本无意遵守这些条款。所以我们不知道他同意这些条款的具体措辞，因为在他同意这些条款后几乎立即发生了一场骚乱，事件非常混乱，行动的具体轮廓不确定。但本质上似乎发生的事情是，泰勒口渴了，天气很热。他要了一壶水，然后一饮而尽，接着他
asks for a jug of ale and then he climbs up onto his horse. And at this point, one of the men in the king's retinue cries out that he is a rebel and kind of denounces him as a thief and a robber. And Tyler is mortally offended at this. He kind of rounds on the guy who shouted out at him. Woolworth, the mayor of London at this point, tries to arrest Tyler. Tyler draws his dagger, lunges at Woolworth. Woolworth strikes out in turn, catches Tyler on the shoulder. Tyler is bleeding really, really badly. He's still on his horse, clinging onto his horse, kind of crosses back across Smithfield
又要了一壶麦芽酒，然后爬上了马。就在这时，国王随从中的一个人大喊他是叛军，并把他斥为小偷和强盗。泰勒对此感到极大的冒犯。他转身对着那个对他大喊大叫的人。伦敦市长沃尔沃斯此时试图逮捕泰勒。泰勒拔出匕首，向沃尔沃斯猛扑过去。沃尔沃斯反击，击中了泰勒的肩膀。泰勒流血非常非常严重。他还在马上，紧紧抓住马，穿过史密斯菲尔德
towards his men, but then he slumps out of his saddle. And as he does so, all the archers that are there in the ranks of the rebels are kind of drawing their arrows and getting ready to shoot. And this is the moment at which Richard II, this famous, famous moment, he rides forwards and he cries out to the rebels, you shall have no captain but me. Just follow me to the fields without, and then you can have what you want. And he starts to ride off and the rebels follow him. And they head out to Clerkenwell Fields, which is kind of north of the city. And Richard II, he's not riding with the rebels. He is
向他的人马走去，但随后他从马鞍上瘫倒下来。就在这时，叛军队伍中的所有弓箭手都拉开了弓，准备射击。就在这一刻，理查德二世，这个著名的、著名的时刻，他骑马向前，对叛军大喊，除了我，你们不得有任何首领。只要跟我去外面的田野，你们就能得到你们想要的。他开始骑马离开，叛军跟着他。他们前往克勒肯维尔田野，那是在城市北边。而理查德二世，他不是和叛军一起骑马。他
escorted at this point by Warworth and Knowles and their soldiers, but he goes to Clerkenwell as well. And Knowles by this stage has managed to raise to Clerkenwell as well. Knowles, by this stage, has managed to raise all the city levies. Clearly, this is what's been happening in the background. Knowles and Warworth have been saying, we've got to muster as much armed force as we can. This is what they've done. Getting to Clerkenwell Fields, there are soldiers now that the king can command, and they surround the rebels. The rebels effectively have no choice but to surrender. Richard allows them to leave. The Kentish men are escorted through the city onto London Bridge so that they can take the road back to Kent.
此时由沃尔沃斯和诺尔斯以及他们的士兵护送，但他也要去克勒肯维尔。而诺尔斯此时已经设法召集了所有城市征兵。显然，这就是背景中发生的事情。诺尔斯和沃尔沃斯一直在说，我们必须尽可能多地召集武装力量。这就是他们所做的。到达克勒肯维尔田野后，现在有国王可以指挥的士兵，他们包围了叛军。叛军实际上别无选择，只能投降。理查德允许他们离开。肯特郡的人被护送穿过城市到达伦敦桥，以便他们可以走回肯特的道路。
The men from Essex and Suffolk head back to East Anglia. Effectively, with this, the revolt in London is over and it collapses as quickly as it had begun. Two questions, Tom. First of all, the numbers involved. We are talking about some thousands of people. We obviously don't know. Yeah, tens of thousands, probably, maybe 10,000. Tens of thousands, right? Maybe, yeah. And secondly, what Tyler? So what Tyler has had the fracas with the Mayor of London. He's suffered this glancing blow on the shoulder, lots of blood. He falls off his horse and then he is what? He's surrounded by his own men and dragged away or what happens to him? Yeah. And they take him to the hospital. They've got the hospital of St. Bartholomew behind them. They take him to hospital
来自埃塞克斯和萨福克的人回到了东安格利亚。实际上，随着这一点，伦敦的起义结束了，它开始得快，结束得也快。两个问题，汤姆。首先，涉及的人数。我们谈论的是几千人。我们显然不知道。是的，可能有几万人，也许一万。几万人，对吧？也许吧，是的。其次，泰勒呢？那么泰勒和伦敦市长发生了骚乱。他的肩膀受了擦伤，流了很多血。他从马上摔下来，然后他怎么了？他被自己的人包围并拖走了，还是发生了什么？是的。他们把他带到医院。他们身后有圣巴塞洛缪医院。他们把他带到医院
and while he's in the hospital, he gets arrested by Woolworth's men and they drag him out into Smithfield and they chop his head off. Right away? Yeah. No show trial or anything? No show trial. Just that's the end of him? That's the end of him. Yeah. Right. Okay. And so the rebellion is effectively over. Now, the question is, is this all planned? And I think it must have been. The idea that you take the rebels up to Clerkenwell, you essentially surround them,
当他在医院时，他被沃尔沃斯的人逮捕了，他们把他拖到史密斯菲尔德，砍下了他的头。马上？是的。没有作秀审判之类的吗？没有作秀审判。就这样结束了？就这样结束了。是的。好吧。好的。所以起义实际上结束了。现在的问题是，这一切都是计划好的吗？我认为一定是。你把叛军带到克勒肯维尔，你基本上包围了他们，
you disarm them. I mean, it's done very, very effective. It's kind of like kettling. It's what the police do with rioters now, isn't it? I mean, that's effectively what they do. And the thing with what, Tyler, was that all planned? Was that orchestrated? We don't know. It seems to be such a chaotic thing. I mean, yeah, maybe. We just don't know. But what we also don't know, and I think this is a much more interesting question, is what is the attitude of Richard to all this? So there is a notorious thing that he's meant to have said a couple of weeks after the suppression of the revolt in London, where he has gone out into Essex as part of the commissions that are attempting to pacify the county. And he is addressed by villains, by peasants, by serfs
你解除了他们的武装。我的意思是，这做得非常非常有效。这有点像“围堵”。这就是警察现在对暴徒所做的事情，不是吗？我的意思是，这实际上就是他们所做的。关于泰勒的事情，那是计划好的吗？那是精心策划的吗？我们不知道。这似乎是一件非常混乱的事情。我的意思是，也许吧。我们只是不知道。但我们也不知道，我认为这是一个更有趣的问题，那就是理查德对这一切的态度是什么？所以有一件臭名昭著的事情，据说他在伦敦起义被镇压几周后说过，当时他作为试图安抚该郡的委员会的一部分去了埃塞克斯。他被来自埃塞克斯的恶棍、农民、农奴所质问，
from Essex who come to him and ask him for the rights that he had promised them at Mile End and at Smithfield. Richard supposedly says to them, rustic-y you were and rustic-y you remain, so rustic-y country dwellers, peasants. You will continue in bondage not as previously, but in conditions incomparably harsher. But this again, he doesn't say this. This is a bit like Walsingham's invention of the sermon that John Ball gives. It's kind of monkish wish fulfillment. And I think the evidence is that Richard is actually pretty reluctant to go back on certainly the promises that he had given at Mile End,
他们来到他面前，要求他兑现他在迈尔恩德和史密斯菲尔德向他们承诺的权利。理查德据称对他们说，你们过去是乡巴佬，现在依然是乡巴佬，所以乡巴佬、乡村居民、农民。你们将继续处于奴役状态，不是像以前那样，而是在无法比拟的更严酷的条件下。但这又是，他并没有这么说。这有点像沃尔辛厄姆编造的约翰·鲍尔的布道。这是一种僧侣式的愿望实现。我认为证据表明，理查德实际上非常不情愿收回他在迈尔恩德所做的承诺，
so to abolish serfdom and tolls and so on, and to issue a general pardon. Because it's actually not until the 2nd of July, so that's a good fortnight and more after the suppression of the revolt in London, that he reverses all those promises. And what this does, it kind of gives scope for rebels out in East Anglia to feel that, as they do, they target the great abbey of Bury St. Edmunds. They storm the abbey, they behead the prior, but they're kind of doing the king's will at St Albans, which also has a great abbey that again, all the familiar stuff, they burn all the records. And at Cambridge, I mean, it's amazing. We have no records of the university at Cambridge from before 1381 because they were all destroyed.
即废除农奴制和通行费等等，并发布大赦。因为实际上直到7月2日，也就是伦敦起义被镇压两周多后，他才推翻了所有这些承诺。而这所做的是，它给了东安格利亚的叛军一种空间，让他们觉得，正如他们所做的那样，他们以贝里圣埃德蒙兹大修道院为目标。他们冲进修道院，斩首了院长，但他们有点像是在圣奥尔本斯执行国王的意志，那里也有一个大修道院，同样，所有熟悉的东西，他们烧毁了所有的记录。而在剑桥，我的意思是，这太令人震惊了。我们没有1381年之前剑桥大学的任何记录，因为它们都被销毁了。
And there's a kind of very, very famous account of a woman called Marjorie Starr, who as the records of the university were going up in smoke, danced around the bonfire, picking up the ashes and hurling them on the breeze and shouting, away with the learning of clerks, away with it. Crikey. Sounds like Tony Blair's son, Ewan Blair. He's trying to get people not to go to university and do apprenticeships. He would enjoy that moment. Well, he would. The Marjorie star of our day. And disturbances, it's not just in East Anglia. You get them in Bridgewater and Somerset. You get them in York. You get them in Beverly, north of Humber. So the bushfires are smoking across the country, Dominic, but they are about to be stamped out.
有一个关于一个叫玛乔丽·斯塔尔的女人的非常非常著名的描述，当大学的记录在烟雾中升起时，她在篝火旁跳舞，捡起灰烬扔向微风，大喊，让文人的学问见鬼去吧，让它见鬼去吧。天哪。听起来像托尼·布莱尔的儿子尤安·布莱尔。他试图让人们不要去上大学，而是去当学徒。他会喜欢那一刻的。嗯，他会喜欢的。我们这个时代的玛乔丽·斯塔尔。骚乱，不仅仅是在东安格利亚。你在布里奇沃特和萨默塞特也有。你在约克也有。你在亨伯河以北的贝弗利也有。所以野火正在全国蔓延，多米尼克，但它们即将被扑灭。
So Tom, there's a lovely comparison here. Things like the Pilgrimage of Grace in the 16th century. There's a pattern in English history that these sort of revolts happen. And the king says, fine, you can have what you want. You're a good man. I will honor your justifiable grievances. And then they all go home and they say, hurrah, hurrah, the king. And then three weeks later, the king's men turn up and kill them all. I mean,
所以汤姆，这里有一个可爱的比较。像16世纪的“恩典朝圣”之类的事情。英国历史上有一种模式，这种起义会发生。国王说，好吧，你可以得到你想要的。你是个好人。我会尊重你们正当的申诉。然后他们都回家了，他们说，万岁，万岁，国王。然后三周后，国王的人出现了，把他们全杀了。我的意思是，
it's even like the Prigozhin revolt in Russia, right? The mutiny there. Except that this is the first. Nothing like this has happened. But Richard II and his men have stumbled on a formula that always works. Tell them they can have what they want and then kill them later. Richard's advisors definitely have. I mean, as I say, Richard's own attitude is more ambivalent. And I think the memory of how the vast mass of the common people had respected his authority and it stays with him and is hugely influential on the estimation that Richard will have of his own charisma and of the degree to which he is loved by the mass of his subjects. This will have an enduring impact on the future course of the reign. But he's still just a boy, and so he is not responsible for the repression that now happens.
这甚至像俄罗斯的普里戈任叛乱，对吧？那里的兵变。除了这是第一次。从来没有发生过这样的事情。但理查德二世和他的手下偶然发现了一个总是有效的公式。告诉他们他们可以得到他们想要的，然后以后再杀了他们。理查德的顾问们肯定发现了。我的意思是，正如我所说，理查德自己的态度更矛盾。而且我认为广大普通民众如何尊重他的权威的记忆留在了他心中，并对他对自己魅力以及他被广大臣民所爱戴程度的估计产生了巨大的影响。这将对统治的未来进程产生持久的影响。但他还是个孩子，所以他不负责现在发生的镇压。
So you have John of Gaunt heads south. He does his stuff. You've got Thomas of Woodstock. He goes around pacifying Essex. And the absolute star of the show is a guy called Henry Dispenser, who is a descendant of the Dispensers, who were favourites of Edward II. Not a popular family. And he's the Bishop of Norwich. And he is very much a prince of the church. He suppresses the revolt in Cambridge. He goes around suppressing revolts across Norfolk.
所以冈特的约翰向南进发。他做了他的事。你有托马斯·伍德斯托克。他到处安抚埃塞克斯。而这场演出的绝对明星是一个叫亨利·斯宾塞的人，他是斯宾塞家族的后裔，斯宾塞家族是爱德华二世的宠臣。不是一个受欢迎的家族。他是诺里奇的主教。他非常像一位教会亲王。他镇压了剑桥的起义。他到处镇压诺福克的起义。
Basically, he's the hero of the hour. It gives him a tremendous taste for fighting, and he gets so carried away that the following year in 1382, he launches a crusade, not against the Saracens, but against the Count of Flanders. The Belgian Crusade, Tom. You don't talk about that enough. So he launched a crusade against the Belgians and he kills lots of Flemings. And then he gets bogged down in an unsuccessful siege of Ypres, comes back in disgrace. But within two years, he's off fighting the Scots again. Crikey. He's a great man of the cloth.
基本上，他是那个时刻的英雄。这让他对战斗产生了极大的兴趣，他变得如此忘乎所以，以至于第二年，即1382年，他发动了一场十字军东征，不是针对撒拉逊人，而是针对佛兰德伯爵。比利时十字军东征，汤姆。你谈论得不够多。所以他发动了一场针对比利时人的十字军东征，他杀了很多佛兰德人。然后他在伊普尔的一次不成功的围攻中陷入困境，丢脸地回来了。但在两年内，他又去打苏格兰人了。天哪。他是一位伟大的神职人员。
Yeah, he truly is. And by this point, the Great Revolt has been well and truly suppressed. So Wattile has been beheaded. John Ball, he gets captured, tried and executed. Almost 300 of the leading rebels in all get executed. But otherwise, the rebels are confirmed in their pardon. Initially, a pardon is issued, which you have to apply for. So that's kind of acknowledging that you were a rebel. So people are reluctant to do that. Very good.
是的，他确实是。到这个时候，大起义已经被彻底镇压了。所以瓦特·泰勒被斩首了。约翰·鲍尔，他被俘虏、审判并处决。总共有近300名主要叛军被处决。但除此之外，叛军的赦免得到了确认。最初，发布了一项赦免，你必须申请。所以这有点承认你是叛军。所以人们不愿这样做。非常好。
But then Richard does, to his credit, issue another one. He just says, there will be no repression. So I think that does suggest that Richard perhaps has a slight guilty conscience over it. But there's no question that objectively, it seems that the revolt has completely failed. So serfdom is never formally abolished. I mean, there are still traces of it in the late Tudor period. All the corrupt officials, apart from the ones who've been executed in the Tower of London, remain in place. The city corporations, the abbeys and so on, they retain their monopolies and their trading privileges. And John of Gaunt is still by miles the most powerful person in the kingdom.
但后来理查德确实，值得称赞的是，又发布了一项。他只是说，不会有镇压。所以我认为这确实表明理查德可能对此有一点内疚。但毫无疑问，客观上，起义似乎完全失败了。所以农奴制从未被正式废除。我的意思是，在都铎王朝晚期仍然有它的痕迹。所有腐败的官员，除了在伦敦塔被处决的那些人之外，都留在了原位。城市公司、修道院等等，他们保留了他们的垄断权和贸易特权。而冈特的约翰仍然是王国里权力最大的人。
So none of the rebels' stated aims are achieved. And so you might be tempted to say the whole thing had been a complete failure. Except that, I mean, one obvious legacy of it, that there's no more poll taxes. And in fact, there will be no more poll taxes in English history for 600 years. Well, you're thinking of the Margaret Thatcher so-called poll tax. I am. And there was a sense, wasn't there, that a poll tax by definition was toxic in British politics because of the association. Even if people didn't consciously make a link with the Peasants' Revolt and they'd forgotten everything they ever learned at school. Oh, but I think the fact that community charge
所以叛军陈述的目标一个都没有实现。所以你可能会想说整件事完全失败了。除了，我的意思是，它一个明显的遗产，就是没有更多的人头税了。事实上，英国历史上600年内不会再有人头税了。嗯，你在想玛格丽特·撒切尔所谓的“人头税”。我是。而且有一种感觉，不是吗，人头税在定义上在英国政治中是有毒的，因为这种联系。即使人们没有有意识地将它与农民起义联系起来，他们也忘记了他们在学校学到的一切。哦，但我认为社区税
was so rapidly called the poll tax. Yeah. It suggests that there's a residual memory of poll taxes being associated with overbearing, iniquitous government and corruption and all those kinds of things. Absolutely. Which is why it became so explosive when Mrs. Thatcher tried to introduce it. But I think also, you know, going back to the 14th and then into the 15th and 16th century, there is a kind of institutional memory that you can't push the commons too far, that too many exactions and things, it's dangerous. And so that's why I think the memory of it is preserved. And yet the revolt itself is very, very ambiguous, actually, in its character. Because absolutely, it is, as you said, it's remembered as the origin point of English radicalism, egalitarian, progressive, left-wing, if you like. But at the same time, you could frame it in very
被如此迅速地称为人头税。是的。这表明人们对人头税与专横、不公正的政府和腐败以及所有这些事情联系在一起有一种残留的记忆。绝对是这样。这就是为什么当撒切尔夫人试图引入它时，它变得如此具有爆炸性。但我认为，你知道，回到14世纪，然后进入15、16世纪，有一种制度记忆，你不能把平民逼得太紧，太多的勒索和事情，这是危险的。所以这就是为什么我认为它的记忆被保留了下来。然而起义本身实际上在性质上是非常非常模棱两可的。因为绝对地，正如你所说，它被铭记为英国激进主义、平等主义、进步主义、左翼（如果你愿意的话）的起源点。但与此同时，你可以用非常
different terms. You could say, well, it's royalist. It's very hostile to tax and spend. It's committed to cutting away red tape and allowing free enterprise to thrive. So you could equally say, well, it's actually a very right-wing movement. And I think that we talked about how the center of the revolt, it's the home counties, it's Kent, it's East Anglia, which is the hotbed of Protestantism in the 16th century. But of course, Dominic, it's also these are the places that people will go to the new world in the 17th century. And there's a sense, I think, in which you can see many of the themes of American history being foregrounded in the Peasants' Revolt. Oh, that's nice. I like that.
不同的术语来框架它。你可以说，好吧，它是保皇派的。它非常敌视税收和支出。它致力于削减繁文缛节，让自由企业蓬勃发展。所以你可以同样说，好吧，它实际上是一个非常右翼的运动。而且我认为我们谈到了起义的中心，它是家郡，它是肯特，它是东安格利亚，这是16世纪新教的温床。但当然，多米尼克，这也是人们在17世纪前往新世界的地方。而且我认为，在某种意义上，你可以看到美国历史的许多主题在农民起义中被置于前台。哦，那很好。我喜欢那个。
I didn't see that coming. I think that's a lovely idea. Do you think? Yeah, the distrust of the apparatus of government, of regulation, a desire to let aspiration thrive, all of that kind of stuff. I thought you were going to say that all these areas that you've talked about, kind of, I don't know, Suffolk, Kent, Essex, East Anglia, these are Thatcherite heartlands. If you look at the map of Britain in 1979, 1983, and 1987, Margaret Thatcher's three election wins, these are great Thatcherite heartlands, particularly Essex, where so much of the Peasants' Revolt action took place. And of course, Essex is the home of Essex Man, which is this sort of social stereotype of an aspirational, perhaps slightly xenophobic, ultra-patriotic, very sentimental about the
我没预料到。我认为这是一个可爱的想法。你觉得呢？是的，对政府机构、监管的不信任，让抱负蓬勃发展的愿望，所有这些东西。我以为你会说你谈到的所有这些地区，某种程度上，我不知道，萨福克、肯特、埃塞克斯、东安格利亚，这些是撒切尔主义的腹地。如果你看1979年、1983年和1987年英国的地图，玛格丽特·撒切尔的三次选举胜利，这些是伟大的撒切尔主义腹地，特别是埃塞克斯，农民起义的大部分行动都在那里发生。当然，埃塞克斯是“埃塞克斯人”的家乡，这是一种社会刻板印象，即一个有抱负的、也许有点排外的、极端爱国的、对
monarchy, Thatcherite kind of voter. Right. Well, I thought you'd enjoy this. I thought this is a very Sandbrook maneuver to cast. I don't want to overdo it. The egalitarianism that motivates them is incredibly extraordinary. Had Serfdom been abolished completely, it would have transformed English society. But I think there is definitely a kind of proto-Protestant, proto-American, and if you like, maybe a proto-Thatcherite strain within that as well. Very nice. Very nice. I mean, I think if Ken Loach can open a memorial to what Tyler on Smithfield, perhaps Norman Tebbit could open one. Right.
君主制非常感伤的、撒切尔主义的那种选民。对。好吧，我想你会喜欢这个。我认为这是一个非常桑德布鲁克式的策略来投射。我不想做得太过分。激励他们的平等主义是非常非凡的。如果农奴制被彻底废除，它将改变英国社会。但我认为其中肯定也有一种原始新教、原始美国，如果你愿意的话，也许还有一种原始撒切尔主义的成分。非常好。非常好。我的意思是，如果肯·洛奇可以在史密斯菲尔德为瓦特·泰勒建立一个纪念碑，也许诺曼·特比特可以建立一个。对。
Exactly. As well. But Tom, can we end by talking about one person in particular? So you've alluded to this several times. This must have been simultaneously a traumatic, but also a foundational moment for the young richard ii because he's 14 years old he's at precisely the age at which events loom so large for you and they they shape your character and the fact that he has come out of this with his sense of his own charisma his own centrality you know which must have already existed but so enhanced by what's happened,
完全正确。也是。但汤姆，我们能以谈论一个人来结束吗？所以你已经多次提到这一点了。这对于年轻的理查德二世来说，一定是一个既痛苦又具有奠基意义的时刻，因为他14岁，他正处于事件对你影响如此之大、塑造你性格的年龄，而且他从中走出来，带着对自己魅力、自己中心地位的感觉（你知道，这一定已经存在了，但因为发生的事情而大大增强），
that is going to have enormous consequences for him and for England, isn't it? Yes. And it will lead to the great drama of his reign when he takes control. And so, Dominic, we will be continuing our series of episodes on the reign of Richard II next week, where we'll be looking at the extraordinary story of how Richard II ends up being deposed, one of the subjects of one of Shakespeare's great plays. So that's to come. And then after that, we will be looking at a person I like to think of as the most Sandbrookian figure in 14th century England. Wow, didn't see that coming. Which is the poet Geoffrey Chaucer. Oh, that old comparison. For reasons that we will be discussing next Thursday.
这对他是和对英国来说将产生巨大的后果，不是吗？是的。这将导致他统治时期的伟大戏剧，当他掌握控制权时。所以，多米尼克，我们将继续我们关于理查德二世统治时期的系列剧集，下周我们将看看理查德二世最终如何被废黜的非凡故事，这是莎士比亚伟大剧作之一的主题。所以这些即将到来。然后在那之后，我们将看看一个我喜欢认为是14世纪英国最桑德布鲁克式的人物。哇，没预料到。那就是诗人杰弗里·乔叟。哦，那个古老的比较。原因我们将在下周四讨论。
Right. But Dominic, is there a way that people could hear these episodes before we get to them? Yeah. Now, I know lots of people say that they wish they would hear a little bit more advertising for the Restless History Club, and we're very, very pleased to be able to oblige you on that. So if you enjoy Restless History Club adverts, this is your moment.
对。但多米尼克，人们有没有办法在我们讲到这些剧集之前听到它们？是的。现在，我知道很多人说他们希望听到更多关于“其余历史俱乐部”的广告，我们非常非常高兴能满足你们的要求。所以如果你喜欢“其余历史俱乐部”的广告，这就是你的时刻。
The Restless History Club, somebody said the other day that it was cheap. It's not cheap. It's just brilliant, brilliant value, isn't it, Tom? You get early access to episodes. You get to be part of that world-leading, acclaimed chat community, which I think everybody really enjoys.
“其余历史俱乐部”，有人前几天说它很便宜。它不便宜。它只是非常非常超值，不是吗，汤姆？你可以提前收听剧集。你可以成为那个世界领先、广受赞誉的聊天社区的一部分，我认为每个人都非常喜欢。
What other benefits they get? They don't get ads. And they get a monthly live stream. So you get to see Tom Holland's face while he's doing the impressions and talking to you about history and things of that ilk. So that's lovely. And a lot of people really enjoy that, don't they? And very few people sign up and then say they regret it. In fact, they say they wish they could sign up twice by and large.
他们还能得到什么其他好处？他们没有广告。他们有一个每月的直播。所以你可以看到汤姆·霍兰德在做模仿和和你谈论历史以及类似事情时的脸。所以那很可爱。很多人真的很喜欢，不是吗？而且很少有人注册后说他们后悔了。事实上，他们说他们希望他们能注册两次，总的来说。
So you join at therestishistory history.com that's where you sign up and i couldn't recommend it too highly because you'll get to listen to tom's forthcoming episodes right away and you'll get to listen to dominic talking in middle english so what could be more exciting I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news
所以你在therestisthistory.com加入，那是你注册的地方，我怎么推荐都不为过，因为你可以立即收听汤姆即将推出的剧集，你还可以听到多米尼克用中古英语交谈，所以还有什么比这更令人兴奋的呢？我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持“其余是娱乐”，这是你每周的娱乐新闻
reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club
评论，一点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部
if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你想要无广告收听、奖励剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。